[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
près de 20% de la population française
est en situation de handicap mais la
société peine à inclure ces personnes
qui vivent de nombreuses discriminations
au quotidien par rapport aux personnes
valides c'est ce qu'on appelle le
validisme exemple le plus flagrant la
scolarisation un véritable parcours du
combattant
[Musique]
on a même peur d'avoir absolument
personne pendant les premiers mois de
l'année et donc de se retrouver dans une
situation où Martin ne serait pas
accompagné du tout
même difficulté du côté du logement
l'accueil en institution collective est
encore trop souvent le modèle dominant
les associations voudraient davantage de
choix et reproches à ces structures
d'isoler plutôt qu'un Clure mais des
alternatives comme l'habitat partagé
commence à voir le jour
vraiment cette
notion de vraiment être chez moi et pour
entrer et sortir comme bon de me semble
alors comment faire pour que les
personnes en situation de handicap
puissent participer sans barrière à la
vie sociale la France est-elle validiste
c'est le thème de ce numéro d'état de
santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d’état de santé est-ce
que vous avez déjà entendu parler du
validisme non c'est normal c'est un
terme encore très peu connu très peu
répandu mais qui va progressivement
s'imposer dans le débat public pour
faire court le validisme c'est la
conception qui consiste à penser que le
handicap ne permet pas de vivre par
nature comme les autres bonjour Céline
extenseo merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
on va évidemment beaucoup s'arrêter sur
cette notion parce qu'elle est très
intéressante elle bouscule vraiment la
façon dont on pense le handicap et le
validisme vous quel est votre définition
c'est l'idée que une vie avec un
handicap à moins de valeur qu'une vie
sans handicap et c'est quelque chose qui
façonne toute la société en fait le
handicap est souvent
conçu sous l'angle individuel uniquement
c'est un problème qu'on porterait en
nous et qui ne nous concerne quasiment
que nous qu'on devrait corriger
rééduquer soigner alors que ça nécessite
d'être prise en compte comme un vrai
sujet social
et en effet comme une oppression en tout
cas on a l'impression qu'on en parle de
plus en plus on est très loin du compte
mais avant d'aller dans les détails on
regarde votre portrait
[Musique]
et la co-fondatrice du collectif Les
dévalises qui militent contre le
validisme et le sexisme qui selon elle
sont deux systèmes d'oppression liés
tétraplégique à cause d'une maladie
génétique rare c'est l'inextension
témoigne du validisme de la société dans
son blog sous sa plus macérée défilent
des sujets aussi divers que
l’accessibilité des logements la
parentalité des personnes en situation
de handicap et la question des
assistants sexuelles
[Musique]
est-ce que le fait d'être une femme
quand on est handicapé c'est
discriminant une discrimination qui
s'ajoute handicap exactement
c'est-à-dire parfois le handicap efface
le genre on nous
affectualise on nous considère comme des
enfants et donc dénués de sexualité de
plaisir de désir et de vie sexuelle de
vie amoureuse on en prend conscience dès
l'enfance parce qu'on n'est pas projeté
dans une vie amoureuse on nous dit pas
alors tu as des petites amoureux
évidemment
on nous projette pas dans une vie de
parents de
d'époux d'épouse alors que vous avez
exactement les mêmes envies que les
absolument et ma vie sociale est
amoureuse est très riche et va bien mais
on sent ça très jeune donc des gens ré
comme on dit maintenant dans le regard
des autres mais le regard des autres
justement le regard de la société il a
pas évolué quand même on est de plus en
plus présent dans la vie ordinaire dans
la société dans les villes dans les
écoles
et le simple fait de cohabiter
force les gens à ouvrir un peu les yeux
sur la réalité de nos vies loin des
fantasmes validistes véhicules mais
c'est préjugé là s'accroche et émette
beaucoup de temps à se
voir quel était la situation de la
représentation du handicap dans les
médias d'une façon générale à la
télévision particulière infographie
[Musique]
lorsque vous allumez votre télévision
qui voyez-vous dans 94% des cas une
personne valide pourtant près de 20% de
la population française est en situation
de handicap à l'écran l'un des grands
moments de la médiatisation du handicap
c'est bien sûr lors des Jeux
paralympiques ils existent depuis 1960
mais il a fallu attendre 2016 et les
jeux de Rio pour qu'ils soient
retransmis en direct à la télévision
française et les athlètes paralympiques
font souvent partie de ces personnalités
en situation de handicap présentée comme
inspirante et héroïque dont on attend
des leçons de vie c'est ce que les
activistes anti-validistes appellent
l'inspiration porn alors les personnes
handicapées doivent-elles remporter une
médaille ou traverser la Manche à la
nage pour avoir leur place dans les
médias peut-être pas du côté de la
fiction où les personnes perçues comme
handicapées sont mieux représentés
mais elles sont encore trop souvent
jouées par des acteurs valides afin
qu'elles soient vue telle qu'elles sont
sans doute faudrait-il commencer par les
inclure de l'autre côté de la caméra en
2021 c'est dans le secteur de
l'information et de la communication que
le taux d'emploi des travailleurs
handicapés étaient le plus bas tous
secteur confondus le taux de chômage des
personnes en situation de handicap et de
14% presque le double de celui de la
population générale
la télé représente mal les personnes
handicapées mais elles reflète très bien
le manque d'inclusion de notre société
alors c'est l'idée d'extension est chose
qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est que vous
dites que le Téléthon qui est le moment
fort à dire le moment fort où on va
parler des maladies rares et aussi de le
handicap bien vous dites le Téléthon
finalement la façon dont on parle de
nous c'est pas terrible pourquoi c'est
une communication uniquement tournée
vers la charité
vers le vers cette idée que nos vies ne
pourront avoir de salut et nous pourrons
être valables que dans la guérison que
le seul rêve leur rêve suprême de chaque
enfant handicapé doit être de marcher
alors on n'est pas contre la médecine la
recherche
on est OK pour mieux vivre on veut des
traitements qui nous permettent de vivre
plus longtemps et dans de meilleures
conditions mais le Téléthon véhicule
vraiment cette idée d'une normalisation
à tout prix c'est le but de la médecine
aussi
la médecine devrait viser une qualité de
vie et pas une normalisation à tout prix
et vous dites aussi la bienveillance des
gens c'est vrai qu'on est porté à porter
un regard bienveillant à aider avoir un
peu peut-être de condescendants de
commisération la bienveillance pour vous
c'est pas c'est pas ce que vous attendez
on parle de validisme bienveillant il y
a une forme de validisme qui va être un
rejet assez frontal un peu hostile
d'exclusion mais il y a aussi énormément
de validisme bienveillants qui nous pèse
au moins autant et qui est encore moins
reconnu et ça va être de l'aide non
sollicitée ça va être venir pousser dans
la rue une personne en fauteuil ou aider
à traverser une personne aveugle mais
sans nous demander si on a besoin
c'est considéré que seul on n'est pas
capable seul
les gens paniquent de nous voir seul
dans l'espace
publicez comme ça c'est super violent en
fait et les gens viennent nous dire
spontanément qu'on est courageux que
c'est triste je sais que c'est triste
que vous vivez
vous êtes allés à l'école je suis allée
à l'école en maternelle et primaires ça
s'est très bien passé j'ai été intégrée
et au moment du collège j'ai dû être
institutionnalisé parce que c'était en
90 et les établissements scolaires de ma
petite ville n'étaient pas accessible
institutionnalisé on va en parler tout à
l'heure c'est fondamental dans votre
combat c'est le fait d'entrer dans une
institution faut-il fermer les
institutions on aborde ça tout à l'heure
Marianne Cazeau
journaliste d'état de santé est allé
constater comment se pass ait
l'inclusion dans une école à La Rochelle
on a beaucoup parlé de l'inclusion il y
a eu beaucoup de discours politiques
autour de l'amélioration de l'inclusion
scolaire ça semble pas évidemment encore
totalement satisfaisant on regarde ce
reportage signé Marianne Cazaux
[Musique]
Delphine Gan avait un rêve voir son fils
suivre une scolarité ordinaire avec tous
ses camarades mais chaque midi la
réalité se rappelle à elle Martin n'est
pas accepté à la cantine sans une aide
humaine il souffre d'une paralysie
cérébrale qui le handicap dans certains
mouvements et apprentissage mais pour sa
mère Martin toute sa place dans une
école ordinaire
des copains comme tout le monde qui
puissent avoir une sociabilisation comme
tout le monde et qui rencontre
effectivement pas forcément que des
copains handicapés comme lui en effet
parce que parce que je veux qu'il puisse
avoir juste une grande ouverture de
d'esprit vis-à-vis de tout
le rêve de Delphine n'est pourtant pas
utopique dans cette école de La Rochelle
la révolution de l'inclusion a bien lieu
dans la cour de récré comment classe
pour faire les exercices de
mathématiques comme tous ces camarades
oscar a besoin de quelques aménagements
et de l'aide de Pascal il est aesh
accompagnant d'élèves en situation de
handicap donc là ici tu vas voir ce
qu'on appelle le reste ça va être
combien
bien parfait comme tout logiciel te
permet de faire 67
d'accord
[Musique]
dans cette sur cette colonne là et en
parallèle des classes ordinaires les
élèves bénéficient aussi dans saignement
plus personnalisé les aidants s'adaptent
aux difficultés et au rythmes de chacun
ici les moyens humains sont renforcés
avec 5 accompagnants et une enseignante
spécialisée pour 8 enfants
voilà notre premier mot
il faut plusieurs cylindre pour former
des mots
je pourrais faire
voilà
ça ça fait quoi
Jessica audito accompagne Rosario depuis
deux ans
western tu sais ce que c'est
ok c'est avec des danseurs ou avec des
cowboys avec des danseurs
[Musique]
elle a appris à le connaître et à le
comprendre grâce aux ergothérapeutes
kinés et psychologues qui viennent sur
place chaque semaine mais surtout grâce
au temps
le petit garçon que j'accompagne est en
train de faire des progrès mais c'est
même vertigineux en fait c'est c'est
impressionnant et on se rend compte au
fil des jours là depuis quelques mois
que
en fait il lançait beaucoup plus que ce
qu'on pensait et tout ça c'est à force
voilà d'observation d'écoute de de
patience ses enfants là c'est pour moi
c'est essentiel de les accompagner sur
sur le long terme ils ont vraiment
besoin eux aussi de nous connaître et de
nous faire confiance malheureusement cet
accompagnement pérenne n'existe pas dans
toutes les écoles
dans certaines académies les aesh
manquent à l'appel d'après ce rapport
les réclamations relatives à des
difficultés d'accès à l'éducation
d'enfants en situation de handicap
représentait en 2021 près de 20% des
saisines adressées à la Défenseur des
droits dans le domaine des droits de
l'enfant il pointe les difficultés de
recrutement des aesh en raison d'un
statut peu attractif avec notamment des
temps partiels contraints et des
salaires de 800 euros par mois en
moyenne pour les parents c'est une
source d'angoisse chaque année Delphine
remplit un dossier comme celui-ci ça
c'est notre quatrième dossier MDPH
d'orientation scolaire et de demande
d'AVH pour l'école malgré la
notification de la Maison départementale
des personnes handicapées lui accordant
une aide Delphine Gan a vu passer 5 aesh
différents en 4 ans de scolarité de
Martin et la plupart ne sont restés que
quelques mois
on a même peur d'avoir absolument
personne pendant les premiers mois de
l'année et donc de se retrouver dans une
situation où Martin ne serait pas
accompagné du tout et là finalement ces
catastrophique parce que ça veut dire
qu'il avance pas du tout comme il
pourrait avancer avec l'aide d'une
sachant que
tu veux bien
malgré ses désillusions elle ne perd pas
espoir
l'année prochaine elle demandera que
Martin soit orienté vers un dispositif
inclusif comme celui de la recherche
[Musique]
alors évidemment Céline extension quand
on voit se reportage je dis quand même
ça ça avance alors ici ce qu'on voit
c'est c'est une forme de classe Ulysse
qui est pour moi une semi inclusion mais
en fait c'est une inclusion d'un groupe
d'enfants handicapés dans un endroit de
l'école
mais ils vont à l'école mais il reste
entre eux spatialement il reste dans un
coin de l'école et les interactions
alors le progrès c'est qu'ils sont à
l'école voilà ils sont pas en dehors de
l'école donc c'est une demi c'est une
semi-inclusion c'est encore un petit
effort s'il vous plaît je voudrais
parler du de l'accessibilité
des bâtiments sur 100% de vos amis chez
combien vous pouvez aller passer une
soirée moins de 10% c'est moi qui invite
parce que vous pouvez pas aller chez eux
je peux pas aller chez eux 10%
la vie sociale c'est super important de
pouvoir se rendre chez des amis c'est
pas seulement être invité à manger c'est
pouvoir passer à l'improviste c'est
pouvoir venir aider à garder les enfants
déposer des courses quand on a un ami
malade c'est ça fait partie de toutes
ces choses qui qui font une vie une
relation tout le monde peut le
comprendre en vous entendant il y a une
loi en 2019 c'est la loi Elan qui impose
aux constructions 20% minimum
de d'accessibilité aux handicapés avant
depuis la loi de 2005 l'objectif affiché
était 100%. cette loi est lent a fait
reculer à 20%. c'est un recul qui était
justifié par une forme j'imagine de
réalisme mais non il vaut mieux imposer
20 % pour que ce soit appliqué le 100%
qui ne le sont pas c'est ça c'était ça
la logique j'imagine donc pour vous ça a
été une régression c'est une catastrophe
vraiment il y a constamment des
dérogations des reports et énormément de
d'établissements
arrivent à se soustraire à l'obligation
alors évidemment sa nuit globalement
l'autonomisation la difficulté de
trouver des logements accessibles
alors il y a des solutions qui émergent
Marianne Cazeau s'est rendue dans une
colocation qui est entièrement
accessible qui permet aussi à des jeunes
adultes en situation de handicap de
prendre leur indépendance
on regarde ce que ça donne et on en
parle juste après
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la vida Maya comme
tout jeune homme de 22 ans du hardelozo
ne cache pas son enthousiasme
dans la partie cuisine on ne prépare une
repas mais pour lui cela un sens tout
particulier on fait maintenant de
décorer par mes soins la première fois
vraiment cette
notion de vraiment être c'est moi et
pour entrer et sortir comme bon 192 pas
forcément anticiper toutes les actions
un peu comme la vie de Monsieur Madame
auparavant du Hart vivait dans un foyer
la semaine chez ses parents le week-end
en institution ces journées étaient
rythmées par les heures de soins de
lever de coucher et les repas un emploi
du temps régime auquel il ne voyait
aucune alternative
avant de découvrir l'association du club
des 6 à l'origine de ce logement elle a
été pensée par deux soeurs Maëlys
cancler et Maïté board pour que leur
petite sœur puisse quitter le cocon
familial et prendre son indépendance
malgré son handicap grâce à la
colocation c'est aussi ce que souhaite
Dwart Alexandre Cédric et leurs trois
autres colocataires grâce à la
mutualisation de leurs aides ils peuvent
bénéficier sans reste à charge de la
présence d'intervenantes en permanence à
leur côté
en cas de besoin
et uniquement en cas de besoin
car les colocataires sont aussi
autonomes que possible
comme tout jeune qui quitte le foyer
familial ils apprennent à se débrouiller
seul
on aide mais de même ils vont nous dire
ça laisse je peux le faire parce que moi
avant qui était en structure j'étais
habitué à faire pour les autres et ici
c'est tout l'inverse et même pour leur
autonomie pour leur estime de même je
pense que c'est plus sympa quand on
arrive à faire les choses par soi-même
que d'avoir quelqu'un qui vous fait tout
le boulot quoi puis ils sont chez eux
donc ça s'accompagne dans la dynamique
on est chez eux ils sont chez eux ils
font aussi des choses chez eux
chaque midi les colocataires des jeunes
tous ensemble pour eux la vie en
communauté n'est pas qu'une commodité
comme dans toute colocation ils se sont
choisis en fonction de leurs affinités
[Musique]
mais alors que le week-end s'organise
dans la salle à manger Cédric carton lui
pense à son futur
plus autonome que les autres habitants
de la Villa il a choisi ce studio avec
sa propre kitchenette à 32 ans il voit
la colocation comme un tremplin vers
d'autres projets
[Musique]
malgré ses troubles du mouvement et de
la parole il a pu suivre des études il
est diplômé d'un master de marketing
international il cherche aujourd'hui à
faire un stage en entreprise
en attendant de débuter sa carrière et
d'avoir sa propre famille il peut
compter sur celle qu'il a choisi ici
dans la vie de la Maya
[Musique]
alors ce jeune homme de 22 ans doigter
c'est quand même c'est quand même bien
d'être passé d'une institution à une
forme d'autonomie une vie plus
personnelle on voit dans leur portage
que pour lui venant de l'institutions
il imaginait que rien n'était possible
et on lui a proposé cette colocation
cette habitat inclusif et il a trouvé ça
génial évidemment ça paraît mieux mais
pourquoi on lui a jamais dit qu'il
pouvait avoir autant d'aide de meilleure
qualité
seule chez lui alors racontez-nous
qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes chez vous
et ça fait vous raconter ce que c'est ce
système et voilà donc je suis
accompagnée 24 heures sur 24 j'ai 6
auxiliaires de vie qui sera là sur la
semaine
ils viennent par tranche de 24 heures
donc ils arrivent le matin ils repartent
le lendemain matin c'est c'est une
liberté absolument totale et prise en
charge par les MDPH par l'État donc vous
n'êtes jamais à court de solution grâce
à cette présence et cette présence elle
coûte plus cher à la puissance publique
à la sécu ou caisse de prise en charge
que si vous étiez dans une institution
non c'est ça qui est fou c'est que la
société qui cherche à faire des
économies surtout ne prend pas en compte
pas plus cher en fait une institution
c'est des aidants quotidiens mais c'est
aussi énormément de frais de gestion
c'est des bâtiments à entretenir c'est
énormément de frais annexes en fait il y
a une évaluation indépendante qui a été
faite et qui dit que il y a des
évaluations qui ont été faites à
l'étranger je pense qu'en France on
faudrait faire une vraie grosse étude
mais chaque toutes les observations
semblent le prouver ouais donc si on
suit votre logique
c'est une extension il faut fermer les
institutions et donner à chaque
handicapé la possibilité d'avoir ce type
d'accompagnement permanent oui mais je
pense que ça se passera dans l'autre
sens on va pas fermer les institutions
et mettre tout le monde dehors et les
mettre voilà mais dans l'idée
à terme il faudra en venir là est-ce que
c'est une idée qui commence à irriguer
le la réflexion de ceux qui se
préoccupent de ces sujets oui c'est une
idée sur laquelle on est très en retard
en France d'ailleurs il y a l'ONU qui a
qui a fait un rapport
très sévère sur l'état de la politique
handicap française par rapport à la
désinstitutionnalisation en particulier
et qui sommes la France d'accélérer le
mouvement pour permettre aux gens de
vivre de façon autonome et de sortir des
institutions vous avez le des règles ou
une plutôt une des traditions de cette
émission c'est de permettre à l'invité
de poser une question à un représentant
de l'Assemblée nationale vous avez
demandé à Sébastien Petavy député de la
nuque de Dordogne co-président du groupe
d'études handicap et inclusions à
l'Assemblée demandez quel serait pour
vous la première mesure à porter pour
progresser vers la
désinstitutionnalisation en France telle
que demander vous en parliez par l'ONU
dans son rapport du 14 septembre 2021 on
écoute sa réponse
[Musique]
on peut pas fermer aujourd'hui des
institutions si on n'a pas de quoi
accueillir sinon en fait on va le faire
avec avec un accueil qui sera pas
satisfaisant et qui va mettre en fait en
danger beaucoup de personnes parce qu'il
y aura maintenant un bon accueil si on
ne met pas les moyens humains au niveau
de la formation notamment et puis des
moyens financiers
au niveau de l'adaptation de tous les
bâtiments recevant du public on ne
pourra jamais arriver des institutions
[Musique]
voilà donc pour Sébastien Petavy il faut
d'abord mettre des moyens
supplémentaires sur la formation sur
l'accessibilité avant de fermer les
structures c'est dans ce sens là que ça
doit marcher vous êtes d'accord oui on
est d'accord il faut vraiment penser à
tes institutionnalisations avant tout en
termes de proposition et de moyens
à mon avis les moyens existent déjà je
pense qu'il faut penser il faut
réellement penser vie autonome merci
infiniment j'avais envie de vous dire ce
que vous êtes optimiste mais j'ai peur
d'être bienveillante
quand même si je le suis pour être
militant il faut garder un minimum
d'optimisme bien sûr autant que de
colère autant que de colère et vous
dites ça avec un grand sourire merci
d'avoir été avec nous Céline extenso
dans ce numéro d’état de santé merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis et à très vite
sur LCP
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]